- We're back with Lauren Graham.
Give it up, everybody.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- So her new book is called,
"Have I Told You This Already?"
And you can also see her
in the second season of the
"Mighty Ducks: Game Changers"
on Disney+.
I love the show. I'm
a big fan of the show.
- [Lauren] You're so nice.
- Literally, I know you're
here to promote your book
but I was like, "I gotta bring it up."
Like I love the show.
(Lauren laughing)
How much do you love doing it?
It's second season now.
- I love doing it.
The kids are so fantastic.
I just love them so much.
And it just keeps you young, frankly,
to like be around kids.
I know their hip music references and..
- Yeah. Cool mom.
(both women laugh) Your
the cool mom on set.
- It's really fun and
and it's just nice to be in
such a sunny, happy show.
- Oh my gosh, I love that.
I can watch it with my kids.
- [Lauren] Yeah.
- But also when they leave
I still watch it. I love it.
(Lauren laughs)
Well, because Lauren and I share a love
of outer space and pastries
because who doesn't?
And there was no segue there.
(both women laugh)
It's time for another round
of "Planet or Pastry".
♪ Planet or Pastry ♪
(audience applauds)
(Kelly laughing)
- You never thought
you'd sing pastry, huh?
Lauren and I will be on the same team
but we need someone to run the game.
So please welcome a very
funny man who you can see
in his Netflix show "Mo" and
in theaters in "Black Adam".
Here's Mo Amer everybody.
(jazzy music and audience
applauding and cheering)
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Hope you guys are ready for this.
- So excited about your Netflix show
and also "Black Adam" was so good.
Okay, so thank you for hosting.
Could you explain the rules?
- Yes, Kelly. On the table before you
are six covered plates with names on them.
Three of those are pastries
and three are real exoplanets.
If you and Lauren can correctly
identify all three pastries
in only four guesses,
you will win each person
in the audience a prize worth $300.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- That's right.
If you fail, hold on,
there's another part of this.
If you fail, you get NOTHING!
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- Papanasi.
- They all will leave here in anger
and write Twitter messages.
(Kelly laughing)
- I hate her show.
- The bonus is if you guess the pastries,
you get to eat them so..
- Okay. Okay.
- [Mo] Easy.
- Oh God, they all are
very hard words. Okay.
- Sorry to yell, Lauren.
- That's okay.
Tikvenik, what do you think?
- I don't know. Are you ready? Okay. Okay.
Tikvenik. Tikvenik.
- [Lauren] I go--
- Should we say them
all and then like pick?
So we're picking..
Okay, we're gonna pick..
Which one do you think is
a pastry right off the bat?
Which one?
- Ah I think--
- I think Papanasi sounds, I don't know.
Or Papanasi
- Papanasi
- Or Guarani
- Justin Guarini. You were
on "American Idol" with him.
- Let's do it. Let's do it.
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Mo] Oh my God!
(audience laughs)
It is not. This is a planet.
There's 109 light years away
and the constellation Reticulum.
Fun fact, the planet has a mass of almost
two and a half Jupiters.
- I would like to say that
most Mo smells really good,
but he has a secret fragrance.
- He won't tell us. He smells
so good and he won't tell us.
- Don't try to distract
from the fact that you
are failing this audience right now.
(audience laughs) I'll
give you one more try.
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
No we aren't.. okay Papanasi.
Let's do it. Let's just do it.
Just do it. It's a pastry. Rip it up.
Yeah!
(audience laughs and
cheers and a bell dings)
- Oh, that looks good.
- It's like a fried donut.
- [Lauren] Wow!
- [Kelly] Is it a fried donut?
- It also looks like a planet, actually.
It's a Roman..
- I'm trying it.
It's a Romanian fried cheese donut.
- I'm gonna try it, okay, fine.
- [Mo] That's amazing.
- I have the gluten allergy.
- I don't.
(audience laughs)
- [Lauren] I do.
- Oh, that's really good.
- I bet.
- That's really good, congratulations.
- [Lauren] Thank you.
- Great job.
- [Mo] We're on our way to success.
- Okay, wait, what do we think?
- Okay. Yep. That one..
- Tikvenik, Smertrios, Vatrushka
Sounds like it could be like
some kind of dish, right?
It's a pastry!
- [Mo] Vatrushka!
(Kelly and the audience cheer)
- [Lauren] Ooh, that looks
really good. (air horn blows)
- It's a Russian bun similar
to a Danish. Look at that
- [Lauren] Yum.
- Look, we're winning.
- What do you like better?
- Oh my God, this reminds me of kolaches
where I grew up when I was a kid.
- Yeah, your from Texas too, right?
- Yeah. It reminds me of kolaches
- [Mo] Yeah, that's exactly right.
- Oh my God, that's so good.
- All right, you got one more
kid. That's three pastries.
- Okay, 50/50 chance.
- You know what?
It's two pastry, but I'm
gonna give it to you anyway.
Three pastries.
You all win.
(Kelly and the audience cheer and applaud)
- I make my own rules.